bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du plus grands mystères de la physique
fondamentale
celui qui empêche des milliers de
chercheurs de dormir ce qu'on appelle
prétentieusement la théorie du tout la
théorie du tout c'est supposément la
réunion de l'infiniment grand et de
l'infiniment petit l'unification de la
théorie de la relativité générale avec
la mécanique quantique
d'ailleurs on appelle ça plus simplement
le problème de la gravité quantique
alors il ya une approche très connu à ce
problème c'est la théorie des cordes
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de faire une
vidéo sur ce sujet mais aujourd'hui je
voudrais vous parler de l'autre théorie
celle qui est moins connu que la théorie
des cordes mais qui personnellement à ma
préférence la gravité quantique boucle
[Musique]
le problème de la gravité quantique
c'est celui de l'unification de deux
théories qui dans la première moitié du
20e siècle ont complètement bouleversé
notre vision du monde la première de ces
théories c'est la relativité générale le
chef-d'oeuvre d'albert einstein et c'est
une théorie de la force de gravité avant
einstein on avait déjà une théorie de la
force de gravité celle de newton qui
était là depuis presque 250 et c'est
celle qu'on apprend à l'école deux corps
massif satire parce qu'il existe une
force entre les deux et newton nous
donne même la formule qui permet de
calculer cette force
la théorie de newton elle est fabuleuse
elle marche fantastiquement bien depuis
plus de trois siècles maintenant c'est
celle qui permet de comprendre à la fois
la chute des corps mais aussi le
mouvement des planètes
je sais pas si vous réalisez le tour de
force que ça représente pour l'époque
newton comprend que ce qui fait tomber
une pomme vers le sol est ce qui
explique le mouvement d'une planète
autour du soleil c'est la même chose
un truc de dingue réalisation de paul
valéry que j'aime beaucoup et qui résume
bien ça il fallait être newton pour
apercevoir que la lune tombe alors que
tout le monde voit bien qu'elle ne tombe
pas bref la théorie de newton ça marche
hyper bien et l' einstein arrive et
propose de la remplacer par quelque
chose de conceptuellement complètement
différent pour einstein si les corses
attire c'est pas parce qu'il existe une
force invisible entre eux mais parce
qu'ils déforment l'espace-temps l'image
classique c'est celle d'un drap tendu
sur lequel on poserait des objets et
c'est la courbure de l'espace-temps qui
modifie la trajectoire des corps massif
et provoque leur attraction
il ya une chose qu'il faut bien avoir en
tête la théorie d'einstein
mathématiquement elle est très
différente de celle de newton
mais ces résultats ces prédictions
physiques sont essentiellement les mêmes
bah oui encore eux on l'a dit la théorie
de newton marche extrêmement bien donc
la théorie d'einstein
elle a quand même plutôt intérêt à
donner les mêmes résultats si vous vous
amusez à calculer la chute d'une pomme
où la trajectoire de la lune autour de
la terre avec la théorie de la
relativité générale vous allez trouver
la même chose qu'avec la théorie de
newton
sauf sauf quand le champ gravitationnel
devient vraiment intense par exemple
mercure qui est beaucoup plus proche du
soleil que la terre elle est dans un
champ de gravité plus intense hélas le
calcul de sa trajectoire par newton et
par einstein donne des résultats
légèrement différent et c'est le calcul
d'einstein qui colle avec les
observations
c'est à dire que la théorie de la
relativité générale elle améliore la
théorie de newton en particulier pour
les champs gravitationnels intense et
elle va même jusqu'à prédire l'existence
d'objets qui n'existait pas dans la
théorie de newton comme par exemple les
trous noirs les régions l'espace-temps
dont rien ne peut s'échapper
même pas la lumière
et puis bien sûr une des prédictions les
plus spectaculaires de la théorie de la
relativité générale c'est le big bang la
théorie du big bang elle découle de
l'application des équations d'einstein à
l'univers tout entier
elle nous prédit que l'univers n'est pas
une sorte d'arène statique mais peut
être quelque chose qui est en train de
se dilater ou de se contracter
et c'est ce qui a été observé pour la
première fois par edwin hubble dans les
années 20 et puis par plein d'autres
gens après lui toutes les galaxies de
l'univers s'éloignent les unes des
autres
un peu comme un drap élastique sur
lequel on serait en train de tirer de
tous les côtés si on utilise les
équations de la cosmologie pour remonter
dans le passé de l'univers on voit que
plus on remonte dans le temps plus
l'univers était contracté danse et chaud
jusqu'à il ya 13 8 milliards d'années où
d'après les équations l'univers était un
point infiniment danse un peu comme s'il
était né à ce moment là c'est un peu
bizarre comme conclusion lent et on va
voir dans la suite ce qu'il faut en
penser
[Musique]
l'autre immense révolution du début du
xxème siècle c'est la mécanique
quantique la mécanique quantique c'est
un peu le contraire de la relativité
générale c'est une théorie de
l'infiniment petit c'est celle qui
permet de comprendre comment se comporte
la matière au niveau des molécules des
atomes et puis plus petit des protons
des neutrons et toutes les particules
élémentaires
si on doit la relativité générale
presque exclusivement einstein la
mécanique quantique
ll est vraiment le fruit d'un effort
collectif d'une série de génie qui ont
travaillé entre 1900 et 1930
vous voyez si la mythique photo du
congrès solvay 1927
tous les fondateurs de la mécanique
quantique sont là et sur les 29
personnes présentes 17 ont eu le prix
nobel
alors il ya qu une seule femme dans
l'assemblée c'est marie curie mais enfin
elle elle a eu deux fois ce que nous dit
la mécanique quantique ces cas très
petite échelle la matière se comportent
différemment de ceux dont on a
l'habitude à notre échelle est le mieux
pour s'en rendre compte c'est de
considérer un atome d'hydrogène un atome
d'hydrogène en apparence c'est simple un
proton chargée positivement et un
électron chargées négativement et entre
eux existe une force la force
électrostatique de coulon qui dit que
les charges opposés s'attirent cette
force elle ressemble beaucoup à la force
de newton
dit que l'électron doit tourner autour
du proton cette description elle est
simple mais elle a un petit problème
comme l'électron peut perdre de
l'énergie
il va se mettre à tourner de plus en
plus bas de plus en plus proche du
proton jusqu'à venir s'écraser sur lui
un peu comme un satellite peut rentrer
dans l'atmosphère
si ça c'était vrai les atomes
d'hydrogène serait instable
or on voit bien qu'ils sont stables la
mécanique quantique va résoudre ce
problème en venant modifier la vision
qu'on a de l'atome d'hydrogène
tout d'abord la mécanique quantique nous
dit que l'électron n'a pas une
trajectoire bien défini il n'est pas en
un point précis de l'espace sur un point
bien définie de son orbite
il est dans une superposition d'états
comme s'il était un peu partout sur son
orbite à la fois l'autre grand
changement c'est que l'électron ne peut
plus trouver n'importe où il n'a que
certains niveaux d'énergie possible ce
conte symbolise souvent en faisant comme
s'il n'avait que certaines orbite
possible même si c'est pas tout à fait
ça l'électron peut être dans un certain
niveau dans le niveau suivant mais pas
entre les deux et du coup on leur met
des numéros niveau 1 niveau 2 niveau 3
on dit que les niveaux d'énergie sont
quantifiés et c'est pour ça qu'on
appelle ça la mécanique quantique
alors cette quantification des niveaux
d'énergie elle a deux conséquences la
première c'est qu'un électron peut
sauter d'un niveau d'énergie à un autre
en émettant ou en absorbant une quantité
d'énergie bien déterminées sous la forme
de lumière de longueur d'onde bien
défini et ça on le vérifie tous les
jours avec la couleur de la lumière qui
est absorbé ou émises par les différents
at home
l'autre conséquence c'est que l'électron
ne peut pas descendre plus bas en
énergie que le niveau à on appelle le
niveau fondamental et en particulier sa
l'empêchent d'aller s'écraser sur le
proton tout se passe comme s'il y avait
une espèce de force de répulsion due aux
effets quantiques qui protège l atome de
l'instabilité et on va voir que ça va
jouer un rôle important dans notre
affaire
[Musique]
relativité générale et mécanique
quantique les deux énormes révolution du
xxème siècle en physique fondamentale et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui ces deux théories
ont fonctionné merveilleusement bien
on l'a vu encore récemment avec la
découverte des ondes gravitationnelles
pour la relativité générale et la
découverte du boson de higgs pour la
mécanique quantique
et pourtant ces deux théories elles sont
complètement incompatible la relativité
générale nous décrit un monde qui est
courbé mais lisse déterministe à côté de
ça la mécanique quantique nous dit que
au niveau microscopique le monde et
discret probabiliste fluctuant c'est
d'ailleurs assez bien reflété dans les
outils mathématiques qui sont utilisées
par les deux théories qui sont
complètement différents
deux théories aussi bien vérifier mais
qui sont incompatibles
les physiciens théoriciens des tests si
on pouvait remplacer sa part une seule
théorie qui engloberait les deux ça
serait quand même vachement mais il faut
voir que la volonté d'unifier ensemble
et phénomène a toujours été un puissant
moteur de compréhension et à l'exemple
que j'ai donné tout à l'heure de newton
qui unifie le mouvement de la chute des
corps avec celui du mouvement des
planètes
mais il ya un autre exemple encore plus
fou james maxwell qui à la fin du 19e
siècle découvre l'électromagnétisme il
montre que l'électricité et magnétisme
des aimants ne sont que deux aspects
d'un truc plus fondamental le champ
électromagnétique et quelques années
plus tard il comprend que la lumière est
une honte du champ électromagnétique
c'est à dire que d'un coup maxwell
unifie trois trucs qui avant étaient
considérés comme indépendants
l'électricité le magnétisme et la
lumière et ça lui permet d'ailleurs de
comprendre qu'il doit exister d'autres
ondes électromagnétiques que la lumière
visible
eh bien on les connaît aujourd'hui les
micro ondes les ondes radio les rayons x
bref unifiée des phénomènes c'est un peu
la classe mondiale en physique théorique
alors on pourrait rétorquer que unifier
la relativité générale et la mécanique
quantique
on s'en fout un peu on l'a dit la
relativité générale c'est une théorie
des objets très lourd à côté de ça la
mécanique quantique c'est une théorie
des objets très petits as les objets
très lourd en général ne sont pas très
petit ouais sauf qu'il ya deux
exceptions à cette règle
la première c'est ce qui se passe au
centre des trous noirs d'après la
relativité générale toute la matière qui
tombe dans un trou noir va se concentrer
en son centre en un point infinitésimale
un truc très lourd et très petit c'est
ce qu'on appelle une singularité
autre singularité les premiers instants
du big bang on a vu tout à l'heure que
si on utilisait les équations de la
cosmologie on arrivé à cette conclusion
un petit peu étrange qu'il ya 13
milliards d'années l'univers aurait été
un point infiniment danse oui sauf qu'en
fait on n'en sait rien puisque là on
avait à faire quelque chose qui était à
la fois très lourd et très petit donc on
peut pas juste utiliser les équations de
la relativité générale il faut prendre
en compte aussi la mécanique quantique
nous faut une théorie unifiée pour
comprendre les premiers instants du big
bang il nous faut une théorie de la
gravité quantique moquer assez papauté
on la fabrique cette théorie de la
gravité quantique
[Musique]
pour comprendre comment on peut
construire une théorie de la gravité
quantique il faut bien réaliser que la
relativité générale et la mécanique
quantique qu'on veut unifier ce sont
deux théories qui ne se situent pas
vraiment sur le même plan la relativité
générale c'est une théorie qui décrit
une force la force de gravité on devrait
d'ailleurs plutôt dire une interaction
en gros on peut la comparer à la force
électromagnétique la mécanique quantique
c'est pas une force c'est plutôt un
ensemble de principes qui nous disent
comment une force va se comporter au
niveau microscopique on l'a vu tout à
l'heure avec l'exemple de l'atome
d'hydrogène on a la vision classique qui
ne marche pas et la mécanique quantique
vient modifier cette vision pour nous
dire comment les choses se passent à
petite échelle
donc il s'agit pas tellement d'unifier
la mécanique quantique et la relativité
générale mais plutôt d'arriver à
appliquer les principes de la mécanique
quantique à la théorie de la relativité
générale
habituellement on dit qu il existe
quatre forces fondamentales dans la
nature un l'électromagnétisme qui
explique que quasiment tout ce qu'on
voit autour de nous les forces
nucléaires forte et faible qui assure
notamment la cohésion des noyaux
atomiques et la gravité décrite par la
relativité générale et on peut faire
avec ses forces ce qu'on a fait avec
l'atome d'hydrogène c'est-à-dire leur
appliquer les principes de la mécanique
quantique est comme ça on peut par
exemple passer de l'électromagnétisme à
sa version quantique ce qu'on appelle
l'électrodynamique quantique
on peut faire ça aussi avec la force
nucléaire forte et on obtient la
chromodynamique quantique et avec la
force nucléaire faible
ces trois forces dans leur version
quantique forme ce qu'on appelle le
modèle standard de la physique des
particules
parce que tout ce qu'on comprend
aujourd'hui du comportement des
particules élémentaires s'explique par
ce modèle tout ce qu'on voit dans les
accélérateurs de particules jusqu'à la
découverte du boson de higgs au cern
s'explique par le modèle standard alors
appliquer les principes de la mécanique
quantique ça a marché avec les trois
premières forces
il n'y a plus qu'à faire ça avec la
quatrième la relativité générale
ouais sauf que c'est là que ça se corse
je vous ai pas dit comment on fait pour
passer d'une théorie à sa version
quantique
cette opération s'appelle la
quantification et il existe une sorte de
procédure pour la faire elle a été
décrite par un des grands génies de la
mécanique quantique paul dirac d'irak a
proposé une sorte de recettes de cuisine
qui permet de prendre une théorie
classique et de fabriquer la théorie
quantique correspondante
il ya deux problèmes avec cette recette
le premier c'est qu'elle nous demande de
construire des objets mathématiques qui
sont beaucoup plus compliqué que ce
qu'on avait au départ et donc l'arsenal
mathématiques à utiliser peu de vent
vite assez effrayant l'autre problème
c'est que la recette de dire à calais
vague elle nous dit ce dont on a besoin
mais elle nous dit pas comment faire
pour le trouver
si on applique cette recette à l'atome
d'hydrogène on trouve la théorie
quantique de l'atome d'hydrogène
mais si on essaye de l'appliquer à
l'électromagnétisme et ben ça coince
déjà dans le cas de l'électromagnétisme
cette difficulté a été contournée en se
limitant à des situations où les
chambres sont pas trop intense ou bien
une autre manière de le dire où il n'y a
pas trop de particules qui interagissent
c'est ce qu'on appelle la proche
perturbe hâtives c'est un peu comme si
vous vouliez comprendre les mouvements
de la mer et vous décidiez prudemment
vous limiter à l'étude des vagues mais
en ignorant les phénomènes plus globaux
comme les courants ou les tempêtes
l'approchent perturbe hâtive elle est
par exemple suffisante pour comprendre
ce qui se passe dans les accélérateurs
de particules
et cette approche on la doit notamment à
un autre grand génie de la physique
quantique richard feynman fait une manne
a notamment introduit un outil qui bat
n'en porte son nom les diagrammes de
feynman
il s'agit de petits dessins qui
représentent les interactions entre les
particules et si vous ouvrez un livre de
physique des particules vous enverrai à
quasiment toutes les pages alors
pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça est
bien parce que la raison fondatrice qui
fait que construire une théorie de la
gravité quantique c'est compliqué c'est
que la proche perturbe hâtive ne marche
pas avec la relativité générale
si vous essayez quand même d'appliquer
la proche perturbe hâtive à la
relativité générale vous allez toujours
trouvé l'infini c'est à dire vous allez
construire une théorie qui quelle que
soit la question que vous lui posez va
vous répondre
l'infini pas très pratique ce résultat
c'est vraiment l'acte de naissance des
différentes approches au problème de la
gravité quantique parce qu'on avait une
méthode la méthode perturbe hâtives qui
a très bien marché pour les trois
premières forces l'électromagnétisme
forces nucléaires faibles forces
nucléaires forte mais qui ne marche pas
avec la relativité générale donc il faut
trouver autre chose et à partir de là le
monde se divise en deux catégories ceux
qui décide de s'accrocher à lapproche
perturbe hâtives et ceux qui décident de
l'abandonner
je vais pas vous reparler aujourd'hui la
théorie des cordes j'ai déjà fait un
épisode dessus mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'en théorie des cordes
on essaye de préserver l' approche
perturbe hâtives et pour ça on change un
peu les postulats de départ et ça se
fait au prix de l'introduction de
quelques petits trucs exotiques comme
des minuscules cordes des dimensions
supplémentaires
et puis un certain nombre de particules
nouvelles et les particules
supersymétriques une bonne partie de
ceux qui ont voulu essayer autre chose
que la théorie des cordes ont décidé de
laisser tomber la proche perturbe
hâtives et de revenir à la recette
initiale de dirac
et c'est une des origines de la gravité
quantique à boucles mais avant de vous
parler de ça il faut que je vous
explique pourquoi les chercheurs de ce
domaine ont de bonnes raisons
on peut penser que la méthode perturbe
hâtive ne pouvait de toute façon pas
fonctionné toute la philosophie de la
relativité générale c'est que l'espace
temps n'existe plus en tant qu'art elle
fixe dans lequel se déroulera les choses
mais l'espace temps est un objet
lui-même changeant dynamique et une
jolie phrase qui résume sa en relativité
générale la scène disparaît et devient
un des acteurs quand vous voulez faire
une approche perturbe hâtif vous êtes
obligée de réintroduire une sorte de
scène figée sur laquelle se produisent
les perturbations et pour les puristes
la relativité générale ça trahit un de
ses principes fondamentaux et donc c'est
pas étonnant que ça fonctionne pas bien
ok très bien mais comment on fait pour
appliquer le programme de quantification
de dirac à la relativité générale sans
utiliser les perturbations eh ben c'est
dur et c'est tellement dur que personne
n'a jamais réussi
jusqu'en 1986
[Musique]
en 1986 un physicien indien à bail
acheter car propose quelque chose de
nouveau
il propose de reformuler la théorie de
la relativité générale c'est à dire
qu'il prend les équations d'einstein et
il est réécrit différemment
mathématiquement les variables et les
équations qui l'utilisent sont
différentes mais physiquement c'est la
même théorie elle est équivalente à la
relativité générale elle fait les mêmes
prédictions mais sa nouvelle forme la
fait ressembler un peu plus à
l'électromagnétisme et c'est ça qui va
débloquer l'application du programme de
dirac ça et puis les boucles bien sûr
lorsqu'il va venir est un peu technique
mais je suis quand même obligé de vous
expliquer d'où vient le terme de boucle
dans la gravité quantique à boucles
on a vu que la théorie de la relativité
générale elle porte sur la courbure de
l'espace temps
mais comment on fait pour savoir qu'on
est dans un espace-temps courbet parce
qu'on est dedans donc c'est pas
forcément facile de s'en rendre compte
eh ben on fait des boucles imaginez que
vous soyez sur un plan et que vous
teniez à la main une flèche par exemple
une flèche d'arc devant vous
déplacez-vous tout droit pendant un
moment puis arrêtez vous et prenez un
virage à 90 degrés sans changer la
position de la flèche continue à marcher
tous trois puis recommencer à faire un
virage à 90 degrés sans bouger la flèche
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à votre position
initiale à la fin bat la flèche est dans
la même position qu'au départ maintenant
on va jouer au même jeu sur une sphère
qui est un espace courbe
déplacez-vous tout droit puis tourner à
angle droit sans changer la direction de
la flèche avant ses tournées à nouveau
sans changer la direction de la flèche
puis revenez à votre poids initial est
bien là la flèche n'est plus dans la
même direction qu'au départ et ça c'est
le signe qu'un espace et courbes quand
dans un espace courbes ont fait une
boucle c'est à dire un tour et convient
à son point de départ
les vecteurs se retrouve dans une
position différente à tout ça peut vous
paraître affreusement abstrait mais ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que faire des
boucles ça permet de sentir la courbure
de l'espace temps ça permet même de la
mesure est en fête et donc en remplaçant
la notion de courbure par la notion de
boucles on arrive à débloquer la
situation et à appliquer le programme de
dirac à la relativité générale
reformuler par acheter car alors
évidemment je vais pas vous décrire
toute la théorie mais par analogie avec
l'atome d'hydrogène je voudrais vous en
faire sentir les résultats principaux le
résultat le plus spectaculaire il a été
obtenu par deux chercheurs un américain
lee smolin et un italien carlo rovelli
je vous ai dit qu'un des apports de la
mécanique quantique à l'atome
d'hydrogène c'est que les niveaux
d'énergie sont quantifiées discret et
notamment il existe un plus petit niveau
d'énergie est bien en gravité quantique
à boucles
il se passe la même chose avec la
géométrie de l'espace temps en gravité
quantique à boucles les grandeurs
géométriques sont quantifiées les
longueurs les airs les volumes il existe
par exemple une plus petite est possible
que puisse posséder une surface et elle
peut posséder certaines valeurs discrète
pour son air mais pas les valeurs
intermédiaires alors cette dimension
géométriques minimale à son tout petit
la plus petite longueur est d'environ 10
puissance moins 35 mètres ce qu'on
appelle la longueur de planck donc
évidemment à notre échelle on voit pas
la différence
ce que nous dit ce résultat c'est que si
on descend à l'échelle de la longueur de
planck l'espace n'est plus continue mais
il est discret il est fait de petits
blocs indivisible des sortes de briques
élémentaires de taille finie des espèces
d'atomes des espaces pour représenter
cette situation on utilise un réseau qui
symbolise la manière dont les différents
atom des espaces sont reliés entre eux
ce réseau c'est un état quantique de la
courbure de l'espace on appelle ça un
réseau de spin
une fois qu'on a compris ça il ya une
autre question essentielle comment cet
espace évolue-t-il c'est à dire à quoi
ressemble l'espace temps on a vu dans le
cas de l'atome d'hydrogène que
l'électron pouvait passer d'un niveau à
un autre
eh bien il se passe pareil avec notre
représentation quantique de l'espace on
peut passer d'un réseau de spin à un
autre et pour faire ça il suffit
d'imaginer une structure intermédiaire
qui les relie on appelle ça une mousse
de spin cette mousse de spin c'est une
représentation quantique de l'espace
temps et c'est important de comprendre
que tout ça c'est pas juste du dessin en
fait derrière ces mousses de spin il ya
des équations qu'on associe aux
différents éléments de la structure et
qui permettent de décrire la probabilité
que l'espace passe d'un état quantique à
un autre et je vous passe évidemment les
détails mais ce qui reste c'est que la
gravité quantique à boucles nous montre
que l'espace temps quantique n'est plus
un truc glissé continue comme en
relativité générale il est fait de
briques élémentaires de taille finie
quantifier et qui sont fluctuantes qui
peuvent sauter d'un état à un autre
une sorte d' espace temps bouillonnant
[Musique]
je vous ai décrit à grands traits la
gravité quantique à boucles mais
maintenant je voudrais vous expliquer la
cerise sur le gâteau comment cette
théorie va modifier notre vision du big
bang dans les années 2000 il ya un jeune
physicien paul martin boyau valdes qui
s'est amusé à appliquer les équations de
la gravité quantique à boucles au
problème de la cosmologie et il a créé
ce qu'on appelle la cosmologie quantique
à boucles et je vais évidemment pas vous
en donner les détails mais je voudrais
juste vous faire comprendre les leçons
qu'on en tire la gravité quantique à
boucles nous montre que l'espace temps
effet de minuscules morceaux de taille
finie des atomes d'espace-temps une des
conséquences de ça c'est qu'on peut pas
indéfiniment a cumulé de la matière au
même endroit il ya une densité maximale
qu'on peut atteindre la densité de
planque
cette densité elle est monstrueuse c'est
5 10 puissance 96 kg par mètre cube
c'est à dire 5 avec 96 0 derrière et
cette densité maximum elles changent
notre perception du big bang en
cosmologie classique quand on remonte
vers le big bang la densité est de plus
en plus élevées jusqu'à devenir soi
disant infinie mais en cosmologie
quantique à boucles la densité ne peut
pas dépasser la danse cette planque
donc quand on remonte dans le temps au
bout d'un moment ça coince et il se
passe un peu la même chose qu'avec
l'électron l'atome d'hydrogène vous vous
souvenez l'électron peut pas aller
s'écraser sur le proton parce qu'il veut
pas descendre plus bas que le niveau
fondamental et donc tout se passe comme
s'il y avait une espèce de force de
répulsion quantique qui l'empêchait de
s'approcher trop près du proton et ben
c'est un peu la même chose qu'on a en
cosmologie quantique à boucles tout se
passe comme s'il y avait une espèce de
force de répulsion qui empêchait de
dépasser la densité de planck est donc
ça change notre vision des débuts du big
bang
on passe d'une vision d'un big bang à ce
qui pourrait être plutôt un big ben
barnes un grand rebond les calculs en
cosmologie quantique à boucles nous
montre que l'univers a pu se créer de
l'effondrement d'un univers précédent
rebondir à la densité maximale et
s'étendre jusqu'à donner notre univers
alors c'est encore spéculatifs et les
équations sont assez simplifiée mais ça
fait partie des possibilités
alors mauvaise nouvelle ou bonne
nouvelle les calculs montrent que le
rebond a effacé toutes les traces du
passé dans un espèce de grand
bouillonnement quantique serre que même
si cela se révèle confirmé un jour on
aura pas de moyens de remonter pour
savoir ce qu est l univers avant
[Musique]
voilà vous en savez déjà beaucoup sur la
gravité quantique à boucles il faut
quand même retenir deux choses la
première c'est que ça n'est qu'une
tentative parmi d'autres et la deuxième
c'est que tout est loin d'être
complètement achevée dans cette théorie
encore plein de choses qu'on comprend
pas et un certain nombre de choses qui
sur le plan mathématique sont pas mises
sur des bases solides
et puis de toute façon à la fin ce sont
quand même les résultats expérimentaux
qui trancheront qui permettront de dire
si la théorie est correct ou pas
d'ailleurs oui parlons-en des résultats
expérimentaux sur quoi on va se baser
pour vérifier cette théorie est bien la
première chose dont on peut se servir
c'est justement de la cosmologie
vous avez peut-être que la meilleure
preuve du scénario du big bang c'est le
rayonnement du fond diffus cosmologique
qu'on appelle parfois le rayonnement
fossile et dans la manière dont ce
rayonnement fluctue on peut espérer
trouver des traces des premiers instants
du big bang on est encore loin de
pouvoir les discerner mais récemment à
bail acheter car et un physicien
français aurélien barrau on réalise des
calculs pour essayer de comprendre
quelles seraient les signes de la
gravité quantique à boucles dans le
rayonnement fossile et c'est assez
intéressant du point de vue de la
philosophie des sciences parce que ça
veut dire que cette théorie
bah on peut l'attester expérimentalement
elle fait des prédictions même si
aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore la
précision nécessaire
l'autre moyen d'aller tester la théorie
de la gravité quantique à boucles ça
serait d'aller sonder la structure de
l'espace temps la situation elle est
assez proche de ce qu'on a avec la
matière ordinaire si je prends un
caillou et que je le regarde avec mes
yeux ou même avec un microscope et ben
ils allèrent lice il al'air fait de
matière continue mais si je le balance
des rayons très énergétiques comme des
rayons x
j'arrive à détecter sa structure
discrète son organisation en cristal je
vois ces atomes en quelque sorte et il
pourrait se passer la même chose avec la
structure discrète de l'espace-temps
cyber ayons suffisamment énergétique la
traverse
il pourrait nous renseigner sur ces
fameuses atom des espaces alors le
problème c'est que des rayons aussi
puissant on sait pas en fabriquer mais
ils peuvent se produire dans certains
phénomènes astrophysiques et donc on a
peut-être une chance de capter des
rayonnements très très énergétiques qui
portent en eux une signature de la
structure quantique de l'espace temps
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo si elle
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la partager
en histoire qu'on parle pas toujours que
de la théorie des cordes comme souvent
j'ai écrit un petit billet qui
accompagne cette vidéo et qui vous
donnera quelques détails un même si
forcément je vais pas pouvoir tout
expliquer si vous aimez la physique
fondamentale j'ai plein d'autres vidéos
sur la chaîne qui en parle j'ai déjà
parlé de stephen hawking j'ai parlé de
la théorie des cordes de la mecque
cantique des trous noirs de la constante
cosmologique de l'intrication quantique
et c'est une petite chose qu'il faut que
je précise avant que mon accuse sais que
je suis un petit peu partisan dans cette
histoire de gravité quantique à boucles
versus ceux théorie des cordes puisque
en fait j'ai travaillé dans la gravité
quantique à bouquin c'était mon sujet de
thèse et j'ai eu la chance de travailler
avec une partie des personnes dont j'ai
parlé dans cette vidéo
pour ceux qui voudraient me rencontrer
en vrai je peux vous annoncer déjà que
je serai le mercredi 5 octobre à
l'espace des sciences à rennes pour
donner une conférence dans la salle
hubert curien voilà c'est peut être
l'occasion de se voir la marque
comme toujours vous pouvez retrouver les
actus de la chaîne sur facebook et
twitter et vous pouvez me soutenir sur
tipi merci à tous et à bientôt
[Musique]
oui